back now with this Arizona's Democratic
governor mobilizing the state's national
guard to the Border she says she's doing
what the Biden Administration won't
Governor ktie Hobbs taking action after
a visit last week to a Port of Entry
that was so overwhelmed by migrants it
had to shut down you've been seeing the
video and Bill maluan back on the story
in lukeville Arizona you were gone for a
few days you're back now what's it
like and Dana good morning to you well
Governor hob says she is sending the
national guard down here to the Border
because the federal government is quote
refusing to do its job to secure our
border well I can tell you we've not
seen any National Guard out here in
lukeville yet what we have seen are more
mass illegal Crossings take a look at
this footage we shot yesterday afternoon
right here in lukeville more wall
breaches more mass incursions into the
area predominantly hundreds of single
adults Crossing illegally a lot of them
coming in from all over the world some
of the countries we encountered
yesterday from Africa Congo Guinea Sagal
others from Colombia and Ecuador and
listen to these numbers just in the last
3 weeks alone in this Tucson sector
border patrol reports served been more
than 54,000 illegal Crossings and that
does not include any of the known Goda
ways and as usual everything happening
down here is controlled by the Mexican
drug cartels on the other side of the
Border case in point take a look at this
footage we shot uh on the other side of
lukeville in Mexico you'll see there's a
mountain with radio towers our camera is
going to zoom in on it and you'll see a
suspected Mexican cartel Scout up there
with binoculars scanning the area
looking for weak points in the border
wall where they can cut it and move
their human cargo through also take a
look at these images there is a nearby
Indian Reservation here in lukeville
media is not allowed there these are put
out by border patrol where they are
getting pounded with illegal Crossings
every single day this is near the San
Miguel gate you can take a look at these
images there is no border wall here on
this Indian Reservation it's just just a
few little things on the ground uh
people can just walk right through well
the border patrol union says they're
getting upwards of a thousand illegal
Crossings on this reservation every
single day and they only have three or
four agents out there to process all of
it lastly we'll take you out to Eagle
Pass Texas where our Live FOX News drone
is right now you can see the situation
there more mass illegal Crossings in
Eagle Pass as well you can see hundreds
of illegal immigrants gathered there
waiting for processing they've got those
blankets on cuz it's chilly out there as
well uh border patrol sources telling me
more than 2,500 illegal Crossings
happening in that sector yesterday and
CBP has shut down Railway operations
there in Eagle Pass to redeploy CBP
Personnel to help with border patrol
essentially they're stopping
International Commerce to help speed up
processing and back out here live our
team just got word uh a couple miles
away from where we're standing right now
there was just another Mass incursion
into lukeville so we're going to go
check that out right now as we you can
see a suspected human Smuggler actually
driving on the other side of the border
wall from us right now we'll send it
back to you amazing this video is out of
Eagle Pass is incredible thank you Bill
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian killme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis